hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about Clavel anak acid also known as
globulin aid and how it protects
penicillin so you've probably heard of
penicillin which is an antibiotic that
was discovered in the 1920s by Alexander
Fleming it's an antibiotic that is
characterized by having something a
structural component known as a beta
lactam beta-lactam ring that's this
square ring right here with the nitrogen
and the carbon double bonded to an
oxygen so it's either beta-lactam ring
of course there are other structurally
related antibiotics derivatives of
penicillin things like ampicillin and
amoxicillin and stuff allows for hands
and penicillin and these related
antibiotics can actually be inactivated
by inhibitors like a group of enzymes
known as beta lactam Isis so beta
lactamase is our an enzyme and they
actually cleave the beta-lactam ring
they cut it and then penicillin no
longer works to inhibit bacterial growth
because the the structure has been
disrupted by the cleavage of that beta
lactam right now resistance to
penicillin is becoming very common
because these beta lactam aces are
present and so many bacteria now there
are a lot of medical isolates now that
are resistant to penicillin and so other
drugs have to be used instead resistance
is also growing to those other drugs and
so you can see why this would be a
problem now luckily resistance to
penicillin and others are structurally
related antibiotics can be countered by
combining these beta lactam and
biotics with beta-lactamase inhibitors
so compounds that will inhibit the beta
lactamase is to keep them from cleaving
the rain that beta-lactam ring and
penicillin and related drugs an example
of a beta-lactamase inhibitor is
clavulanic acid again that's also known
as cloudy laminate sometimes an example
is augmentin so if you've ever been
prescribed augmentin you probably looked
at the box and saw it was a mixture of
amoxicillin which is one of these
structurally related antibiotics it has
that beta-lactam ring and clavulanic
acid and so the two are there together
so let's look at how they work here I've
drawn the structure of penicillin and
related drugs so they've got slightly
different R groups here but otherwise
quite similar and now here is the
structure of cloudy ionic acid and in
red I've noted the similarities and so
you can see how much cloudy ionic acid
looks like penicillin and related drugs
and so the mechanism through which it
interferes with these beta lactam aces
is it actually binds to the active site
of beta lactam aces so what is the
active site to have an enzyme the active
site of an enzyme is the place where the
substrate binds for the enzyme to act on
so normally beta lactam aces would bind
penicillin and related drugs and cleave
that beta-lactam ring but instead the
beta lactamase will bind clavulanic acid
which is similar enough to its normal
substrates to find that active site but
dissimilar enough that the beta lactam
aces can't actually cleave the ring and
so it's a way of just kind of jamming
off the beta lactam aces you've got this
Club you land
I said sitting in the active site of the
beta lactamase so it can no longer in
activate the co-administered drug
whether that's penicillin or amoxicillin
or ampicillin or whatever and so
basically these blocks that enzyme from
being able to work so does that solve
all of our problems with antibiotic
resistance does that mean that we can
just administer penicillin and related
drugs easily now not exactly and the
reason for that is because the bacteria
are able to in some cases overcome this
CLAB Yelena acid defense for example
some bacteria exhibit increased
production of beta lactam Isis what that
means is they make so many beta lactam
aces but all of the clavulanic acid all
of the primal Anik acid in a drug can
get used up blocking active sites of all
of those beta lactam aces and there
would still be even more left over to
inactivate the co-administered drug so
that's one way in which we've got
resistance to climb Atlantic acid
another way is that some bacteria have
mutated their beta lactamase so their
beta lactamase they've mutated it in
such a way that clavulanic acid no
longer binds it but the beta lactamase
is still able to bind penicillin and
related drugs and cleave that
beta-lactam ring so that's certainly
dangerous another possibility for
bacteria to obtain resistance to cloudy
ionic acid is by H GT and which of
course stands for horizontal gene
transfer this refers to things like
transformation and transduction and
conjugation ways in which bacteria can
exchange genetic material with each
other so there are bacteria that can
acquire a new beta lactamase basically
one of these mutated ones by horizontal
gene transfer and then be able to still
break down penicillin and the
and drugs despite the presence of
globulin and acid and so while we still
have clinical uses for clavulanic acid
[Music]
to be useful in overcoming infections
it's not a cure-all because we are
having resistance building up to cloudy
landing acid now as well if you're
interested in learning more about either
enzymes and active sites you can see my
video on introduction to enzymes I also
have multiple videos on horizontal gene
transfer videos on conjugation
transformation transduction so check
those out if you are interested and
thanks for watching biology professor